the infrastructure bill yesterday
absolutely
torpedoed by an 87 year old
politician here's what happened we had
over the last week a 550 billion dollar
infrastructure bill that was put
together as part of that bill
there was a section a couple of
paragraphs that was going to use
more onerous tax reporting requirements
to help pay for the bill it was
estimated that over 20 billion dollars
maybe as much as 28 billion dollars was
going to be generated in revenue
from this new part of the bill now where
they get 28 billion dollars
i have no clue i don't think they know
either it's a
guesstimate they basically pretend it's
an estimate but really they're guessing
and so 28 billion was the guesstimate as
to how much revenue could be derived
from this
but as the bill got put forward the
language was
very very concerning to market
participants both investors
entrepreneurs operators and also
government lobbying organizations all
said wait a second
this language drastically expands the
definition of a broker
a broker historically has been somebody
who allows party a
and party b to transact with each other
think of that as like a crypto exchange
but with the definition of broker it
became apparent that
maybe somebody like a miner could be
considered a broker
or what about a software developer the
legislation was asking people to do
something in terms of reporting 1099s
and tax
structures that they actually could not
do if you are a software developer
and you put software out in the world
are you going to issue a 1099 every time
somebody uses your software
well if you're not in exchange it may be
hard to do that
and so that was the big controversy
there was multiple
amendments that were proposed from
different sides of the aisle
and also different parties or
politicians luckily for
us through all of the advocating the
calls of the senators the tweets all
this stuff
all the politicians came together they
worked and they worked they were
up late at night probably using candles
to look at their pieces of paper and
what they realized
was the most important thing here
was to reach an agreement that would
create a
better structure for that definition of
a broker
and for this crypto provision they then
ran it by reportedly the white house the
treasury
etc and when they got thumbs up everyone
said this is good
bipartisan support unelected official
support
and it got put forward on the floor but
because of
the way that the amendment was put
forward what we needed
was for no politician to object
we just need everyone to say thumbs up
when we think of democracy we usually
think of
majority vote you need 51 or more of the
vote and you can get things done
but in this specific situation because
of the structure of the way that the
amendments were put forward
we actually needed a hundred percent of
people to agree well
of course when you have a hundred
senators two from every state
there's always somebody who's gotta ruin
the party
and the person who's getting majority of
the blame for ruining the party is
senator from alabama his name is senator
shelby he is 87 years old
87 years old
and he was able yesterday to object say
nope i don't want this
not gonna happen on my watch i don't
like this amendment
but he didn't have any opinion on
bitcoin cryptocurrencies
taxes or anything else he simply
was being spiteful because he wanted
50 billion dollars more in the bill for
defense spending
and he didn't get it this is the
equivalent
of john and i going somewhere and when i
ask for something and they tell me no
and then john
asks for something else and they say yes
i ruin it for them
it's spiteful it's stupid and it's what
we expect of
four-year-olds not 87 year olds that are
elected officials that are there
to represent the will of the people but
senator shelby had his own plan
he decided to be an idiot and he decided
to end up being spiteful so
because he didn't get his 50 billion
dollars for defense spending
he ended up torpedoing the amendment now
here is the most fascinating part at 87
years old it is impossible
for senator shelby to have any opinion
on most technology let alone
this new area of innovation on top of
that
when you look at his biggest donors
surprise
it's defense contractors so here we have
the exact thing that most people in the
bitcoin or cryptocurrency industry
is going against we have an incumbent
87 year old politician who has
no reason to be governing
at this point in his career who also has
already said that he will be retiring
after this session and on his way out
the door
he basically kicked and obliterated
one of the most innovative industries
for the future
the old person ended up saying to
themselves
i don't care about the future
because i wasn't able to get 50 billion
dollars
for the past now i have nothing against
older people actually i've learned more
from older people than probably younger
people
through my career and through my life
but what i do have a problem with
is when we have people who know nothing
about an industry having the ability
to govern it and having the ability to
stand in the way
and so i'm not the only person who
believes this
ted cruz the second time in a
two days that we're going to talk about
ted cruz ted cruz
stood in front of the senate and
absolutely destroyed them it was
incredible
so here's part of what ted cruz had to
say yesterday we're going to play it
and when you hear what ted cruz had to
say i want you to sit there and think
for a second
that he is talking about one of the
areas of innovation economic prosperity
and job creation for america
and there's an 87 year old politician
who ended up saying
no and just threw his middle finger up
to an entire industry
so here's what ted cruz had to say
this overly broad definition those who
would have to collect information on
cryptocurrency
cons consumers and report this
information to the irs
it would force every single participant
in the cryptocurrency structure
to operate as a financial institution
which would mean they would have to
provide consumer information to the irs
even if they don't have access to that
information
so this overly broad definition of the
word broker
will block rapid innovation in
cryptocurrencies and it will endanger
the privacy of many americans and
cryptocurrencies
this is wrong so i applaud my colleagues
for trying to find an incremental
approach unfortunately
because the senator from vermont
objected that incremental approach
hasn't been adopted
so let's exercise a brief shining moment
of common sense
and let's recognize if we've gathered
all 100 senators in this chamber
and asked them to stand up and
articulate two sentences
defining what in the hell a
cryptocurrency is
that you would not get greater than five
who could answer that question
given that reality
the barest exercise of prudence would
say we shouldn't regulate something we
don't yet understand we should actually
take the time
to try to understand it we should hold
some hearings we should consider the
consequences
we shouldn't destroy people's lives and
livelihoods
from complete ignorance now
there's a lot of people who don't agree
with a lot of things that ted cruz has
said
done or believes but that might be one
of the most rational
thoughts around this entire debacle
is how can we ask a group of 100 people
with his estimation less than 5 percent
of them could even describe what the
industry is or what the assets are
and ask them to govern it we can't but
my biggest takeaway from this
is not anything to do with bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies
it's actually not even anything to do
with innovation because i think that
america will continue to be innovative
entrepreneurs and
investors will be told what rules are
and they'll still continue to operate
within them some will leave and go
elsewhere
some will stay and innovate but my
biggest takeaway from this entire
situation
is that the government may be one of the
most
ineffective and inefficient
organizations
in the world the fact that we have
gotten a front row seat
as i described yesterday bitcoin taught
me economics
bitcoin taught me personal finance and
now bitcoin is teaching me politics
and i don't like it because we have
people
who know nothing who are making the
rules that govern the people
who know everything and so when you
think
through that dichotomy what it suggests
is where else are they making mistakes
where else is this happening
what about health care what about
monetary policy or fiscal policy
where else is the government making
rules where they know nothing
about the topic probably more than we
think hey guys thanks so much for
watching that clip of the best business
show
make sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday
and then head to sofi.com so that you
can get an account we can get after it